cuando hagan un examen ap de biología es
probable que les incluyan un formulario
como este y al principio puede ser un
poco intimidante porque en una clase de
biología no estamos acostumbrados a ver
este tipo de fórmulas de cálculo pero lo
que veremos en este vídeo es que esta
fórmula simplemente no se expresa algo
pero que en realidad no necesitamos del
cálculo ni tampoco del álgebra porque lo
podemos determinar intuitivamente pero
al final lo relacionaremos para que vean
que todo tiene sentido entonces
olvidémonos por un momento de esto y yo
les voy a hacer una simple pregunta pero
primero supongamos que estamos
estudiando una población y encontramos
que la tasa de natalidad
la tasa de natalidad de esta población
es igual a 60 supongamos que estamos
estudiando una población de conejitos 60
conejitos
por año
y supongamos que la tasa de mortalidad
la tasa de mortalidad
es igual a 15 conejitos
por año
ahora sin poner atención al formulario y
solamente a los datos cuál será la tasa
de crecimiento poblacional para esta
población de conejitos pausa en el vídeo
y vean si pueden resolver bueno para
saber cuál es la tasa de crecimiento
poblacional en un año aquí podemos ver
que la población crece en 60 conejitos
por año entonces crece 60 conejitos por
año pero al mismo tiempo se reduce por
15 conejitos que mueren 15 conejitos al
año así que en ese año terminamos con 45
conejitos netos y esa es una taza porque
estamos diciendo que ocurre por año
entonces el crecimiento es de 45
conejitos en ese año y esa es nuestra
tasa de crecimiento poblacional observen
que lo que acabamos de hacer fue muy
intuitivo no necesitamos de matemáticas
avanzadas para resolverlo y miren
exactamente lo que nos dice esta fórmula
porque la notación de algo
dt es la tasa en donde ese algo cambia
con respecto al tiempo pero esta es
solamente una forma elegante de decir
cuál es la tasa a la que la población
cambia con respecto al tiempo y también
existen otras formas en las que
podríamos haberlo escrito si no queremos
usar el cálculo por ejemplo podríamos
simplemente haber escrito un cambio en
la población con respecto a un cambio en
un tiempo dado la letra griega delta se
refiere a un cambio y lo que nos dice
esta fórmula es exactamente lo que
hicimos la diferencia entre la tasa de
natalidad que es la letra be mayúscula
en esta fórmula esta es nuestra tasa de
natalidad y la tasa de mortalidad que en
esta fórmula es la letra d que la
pusimos aquí así que esto es muy
intuitivo
si yo estuviera a cargo del formulario
tal vez lo habría puesto un poco
diferente tal vez se hubiera puesto una
notación como esta o tal vez se habría
usado otras letras en lugar de b y de
para que coincidieran con las palabras y
sus significados en español así quedaría
más claro que son tasas o proporciones
pero como pueden ver en este ejemplo
solamente se trata de expresar algo que
además de que es muy sencillo no
necesitamos de una fórmula para
resolverlo